Ah ah this is a toughy I
Studied ap us history for an entire school year now
I'm interested to see if that was worth it or like a total waste of a year of my life
I read that like test prep book like three times odds of being able to watch a movie [during] that class or always much higher
[than] most other classes which I appreciate it
I did okay on the ap test at the end of the four, but in the class
I think I gotta see ap us history was a push as the kids called it one of the worst decisions
I've ever made in my life, so I feel like this is going to go
Probably not so well hmM, okay?
What year was the Boston massacre? I'm not very good with [years] that's probably why I'm not gonna history
I do remember this massacre being referred as I shot that ring around the world you can put a lower third saying how long I?
Am
Seventeen sixty nine
Sixty percent confident yay. Oh my God yay, okay. Damn it. I was only one year off
Which would be impressive if it wasn't multiple choice the federalist papers were written by Alexander
Hamilton James Madison and who okay. It's either John Hancock or John Adams
I think because I recognize those names above John Hancock can do shit except write his name really big
I'm not upset that. I don't know this because of a push. I'm mad I don't know this because I listened to Hamilton
I'm gonna go with John J. I got it right yay
I love this this is the best five on the test you gotta get none of these right the trail of tears
Forced relocation of each tribe leading to the deaths of thousands of native Americans
I don't think it was the sioux the super pretty north yeah, can I have [a] lifeline cherokee? Yes?
Hey got a second question run
I feel especially bad about this one because I actually did a report on the cherokee in Elementary school. What is the 14th amendment?
God, this is probably a really important one
I could probably figure it out better if I knew what the 11th 12th and 13th floor
But I also don't know that. Oh yeah, that's the abolition of slavery. I hope son of a bitch
Why wasn't that earlier? Okay complete? How are the best is I'm gonna do better it's Gonna be fine
I got this what does this political cartoon best represent we got like an uncle Sam guy?
Unlike some sort of hemisphere with a hat and like a bowl and some other three guys in the background
I mean, I know what this is saying, but I don't know what idea
This is representing that doesn't make any sense if you like its manifest destiny or a social Darwinism it just sounds right
But this has got to be the monroe doctrine which is like protecting everything in our sphere of influence
Whoo Ida Tarbo is a famous example of the terms all sound familiar, but I don't remember
What any of them means sounds like pretty pointless to have that knowledge in my head of just?
Remembering what the word sound like muckraker. I don't remember what a muckraker is can I know what I muckrakers. What's the muckraker?
What's a muckraker none of these people know either? It's not as me
Oh, I know that's brown versus board of education and Rivers. What court case
I nina. I know this woman. I can't even narrow down oh, man
I'm laughing because the answer I know none of the answers. I'm gonna go with Marbury be Madison. Oh
My gosh, wait. I'm done. I memorize all these facts, and [I] remember [I] thought it was really important now
I'm like I don't know how important. It was anymore
I came here thinking
I was gonna get every single question wrong and I got Melissa questions wrong
But I at least I got like a few correct. I wanted to do better
I thought I knew more I had no study prep time and I am old
Bye